[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday 12th of may
i'm cindy you the spectator's broadcast
editor and your host this week
on the show
in the spectator's cover story this week
katie borce asks whether kierstarma can
escape beergate and looks at who might
replace him katie will join me alongside
james forsythe and guardian columnist
rafael baer to discuss
while much of the conversation has been
about the party leaders more than a
hundred thousand fines issued to
ordinary people who broke lockdown rules
are still going through the british
courts michael simmons will be on the
show to tell us about them
on the other side of the world australia
is in the middle of an election campaign
who's going to win and has conservatism
fallen out of fashion there i'll speak
to former foreign minister of the
liberal party alexander downer
has oxford ruined britain toby young
writes his column this week about simon
cooper's new book chums which looks at
how a group of elite graduates from the
university took over our politics toby
and simon will join us for debate and
finally roger hardy's illustrated
history of palestine is reviewed in the
books pages of this week's magazine
he'll join us to tell us about that
pivotal century before the establishment
of israel
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and of investment
managers who go above and beyond to
offer you support and guidance just
visit can do wealth dot com to find out
more
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of the video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
first up have the tories screwed up
beergate kirsten has promised to resign
if he is fined giving labour the
opportunity to have the moral high
ground katie balls the spectator's
deputy political editor writes this
week's cover piece and takes a look at
the labour mps who could replace him
katie joins me now alongside james
forsyth our political editor and raphael
bear a columnist for the guardian
now katie you write in your cover piece
this week that the tories are actually
regretting pushing the beergate story a
bit too far can you explain
yes so initially we saw tory mps and i
think tory aids pushing beergate pretty
hard and that was for obvious reasons um
i think that clearly if kirstama is
facing questions about alleged covert
breaches it takes some of the pressure
off boris johnson who has been facing
these questions for months now and it's
also a sense so if you can uh take his
stamina and neutralizes the issue it's
much harder for labour to bring up so i
think when on the friday of the local
election results durham police announced
they would actually investigate this
alleged uh breach of rules by kierstarma
last year in durham involving beer and
potentially a premeditated curry
there was a sense of jubilation amongst
tory mps and i think some thought oh
what a lucky politician boris johnson is
um
but i think in the hours and the days
that followed you started to get a
little bit of tory nerves that actually
perhaps this could have been a bit too
successful why is that it's not just
that uh kistama said he resign he will
resign if he gets a fixed penalty notice
which would clearly put some pressure on
boris johnson though i think very few
expect that it would uh trigger a change
in uh response from the prime minister
but i think more concerning is the worry
of well if kirama does end up resigning
um does that mean there's going to be a
new labor leader and actually could that
leader be much worse for the tories and
i think that's a new worry james is
there also worry that if stalmer does
actually resign then the pressure on
boris johnson and also richie cena those
who were fined but didn't resign will be
even greater or what would their next
set be
i think as casey says it would put more
pressure on boris johnson i don't think
boris johnson would resign but whoever
succeeded kissed armor as labour leader
would have a kind of clear dividing line
but that
labor had labor's leader equip because
he was found by the police to have
broken the rules and the tory leader had
not
and i think also there is a concern as
casey alludes to in tory circles that
some of the potential successors to
kierstarma might be more electrically
formidable than he is
katie can you run this through some of
those runners and riders
yes so it's an interesting one having
spent weeks perhaps even months calling
around tory mps and ministers and saying
you know who do you think would be good
to replace boris johnson if he goes um
and getting quite a
lit often downbeat responses and it
actually feels as though there are lots
of potential um candidates uh mps both
on
the tory side but also on the labour
side think could uh do well in the in
the event that kyocerma did have to go
so i think
the front runners are the names you're
hearing the most at the moment are
people like lisa nandy he was the shadow
leveling up secretary former shadow
foreign secretary went the leadership
last time clearly didn't get it but one
of the reasons people were talking about
lisa nandy is there's definitely a
concern amongst boris johnson supporters
who would find it much harder to go
against a woman dominic cummings
remember um
the former number 10 aide and now i
think boris johnson's chief nemesis um
even a while back suggested to labor
that they should ditch starma fernandi
if they wanted to do well thinking that
arguing that a woman from the midlands
would be much harder for the tory party
and would do well for labour
and then i think in that vein people
talk about anderson lorena but i think
uh a some people think angela arena
would land badly with some voters in the
sense they they say oh actually look at
her comments on tory scum this would be
a step too far but also
it's almost a debate that isn't worth
having because you're in a situation
where because angela rainer was also at
the event that kirstarma was at
if one goes you get a sense both will go
and now
there's wes streeting who i think is the
other name whereas there's some
excitement around where streeting and
west reading was received a big
promotion in the last labour reshuffle
to shadow health secretary and has since
become one of the party's strongest
media performers um and therefore lots
of people saying well he could really
take the fight to the tories in that
scenario
uh work there'd be a late labor
leadership contest because clearly we're
talking many hypotheticals and i think
there's some questions that is uh we're
streeting well enough known to win
support the unions which is quite a key
factor in how the contest would work and
also
where does he sit in terms of the
membership because no one is quite sure
where the membership are on these
various issues lots of members left
after jeremy corbyn left the stage
doesn't mean it's now a more centrist
membership i think we're streeting is
seen as a centrist and uh for some
perhaps a little
too much to the right um though i'm sure
he could just spell that in the campaign
rafael let me bring you in here what do
you make of those names that katie has
just mentioned
well i mean in terms of who's ready
who's well known who's not known i think
that's less of a factor just in the
sense that until the vacancy is actually
there you don't really know what the
candidacies look like
in terms of lisa nandy being the front
runner i think that there's a tricky
thing there because she's she's tried
before and i think anyone who's been
sort of served up you know been sort of
sent back to the kitchen you can't
really necessarily bring out the same
meal again
i think that is tricky i think that's
also
would be a bit of a problem for yvette
cooper who's another name who's
obviously
uh introduced um the
i think it's also almost certainly true
that it would be there will be a lot of
pressure institutionally within the
labour party to elect a woman as leader
i think there's a feeling that it's just
frankly embarrassing that the
conservative party has managed to
produce two women prime ministers uh the
labour party's managed to produce none
the only female leader they've had has
been they have been deputy standing in
so that and then on top of that the
feeling that boris johnson's kind of
oxford union swaggery
macho debating style
just doesn't unravels a bit sometimes
when he's confronted with a woman uh and
he i i think that's that that's a minor
issue in terms of the presentation
rather than the policy um for quite a
long time now the labour party has
grappled with this thing kiss dom hasn't
really solved it which is
actually other than being not the tories
what is the easy snappy answer to the
question i am voting labor because
uh and i just think at the moment you
know
when it's just there's so much personal
animus against boris johnson in the
labour party and i think there's a
feeling that since partygate and other
you know
related issues that that might be
spreading a bit further there might be a
feeling in the country that people just
want rid of boris johnson that sort of
anesthetizing labor against the fact
that they really need to answer that
much more fundamental question and i
don't i don't see any leader necessarily
who's in the position to to
automatically resolve that if kia
stammer hasn't done it
and rafael one other thing i wanted to
ask you about is just the role of the
left in the labour party in all of this
because
it's not just the tories who've been
pushing beer gate it's also those people
who
seem pretty disgruntled with
kierstarma's leadership
yeah look i mean there's two i can see
two sides of this really one is that the
the reality is kierstama won the
leadership on the promise of continuity
as much as differentiation from the
jeremy corbyn now he had to do that
because that was the membership we had
as katie absolutely rightly said it's a
very corbyn membership you know there
was a large section of lab party that
just didn't realize i think or didn't
want to accept that the reason labor got
hammered so badly in 2019 is there an
awful lot of people who went into
polling were thinking just the one thing
they definitely knew more than they
wanted brexit more than anything else
they didn't want jeremy corbyn to be
prime minister now by the way i think a
lot of conservatives have misunderstood
that as well and they probably put a
little bit too much emphasis on boris
johnson's magical charisma for bringing
people over probably underestimate the
corbyn push factor anyway corbyn's gone
the membership of labour party has
changed slightly um and kierstalmer has
i think understood i don't know i don't
think it was a cunning evil plan by him
to manipulate the left that much and
think you know i'll trick them into
backing me and then i'll lurch off in a
sort of blairite modernizing direction
or neo new labor uh that his instincts
might have been a little bit more that
than he was letting on but i think
genuine he came to understand how
necessary that would be having won but
the reality is a lot of those people on
the left feel betrayed by by the choice
that he subsequently made and of course
he took the whip away from jeremy corbyn
which is you know a kind of uh
iconoclasm for the radical left but he's
also crucially changed the rules so it's
just going to be harder to get a radical
left mp onto the ballot paper to sort of
do what jeremy corbyn did uh in in 2015
and the fact is corbin only got on the
ballot paper in 2015 because a bunch of
more moderate mps thought it would kind
of in this sort of jurassic park
wouldn't it be cute we could let the
dinosaurs out and kind of pad around in
the meadow a bit but don't worry they
won't win they're not going to make that
mistake again so i i think yeah
ultimately that section of the labour
party likes to be in opposition against
the leader of labour party as much as it
likes to be in opposition against the
tories frankly i mean culturally uh and
and that they will carry on doing that
where it will be problematic is in a
leadership contest the things a more
moderate centrist leader has to do a
little bit as kier did kiss dharma did
to make sure he's got unions and those
people on site that then hem him in
slightly when he goes out to the country
and before i let you guys go as well
james i just wanted to um touch on the
northern ireland uh issue as well
because last week on the show you spoke
to katie about it um can you update us
on what's been going on in the week
since and what viewers should be looking
out for in terms of the government and
the eu's actions on the northern ireland
protocol
so the uk government is uh telling the
eu look if you are not prepared to shift
your negotiating position the uk
government will act unilaterally we've
had the news this morning that the
attorney general has said that you know
the unilateral uk action would be legal
under international law on the basis
that it would be acting to pre to
protect a pre-existing international
agreement in good friday
i think the big question is that whether
the eu is prepared to
negotiate
on more than just the technical
application of the protocol
because
at the moment you're in a situation
where you can criticize the uk
government's tactics you can criticize
the fact that the uk government signed
this document in the first place
and is now so seeking to resolve from it
but you also can't get around the fact
that there is not going to be a power
sharing executive uh in norman ireland
unless you cannot lay the dups concerns
about the protocol
and i i think that is the kind of
fundamental problem now i think you
could you can perhaps argue that the the
british rather than the current tone
they're taking would be better off
inviting mario sascovich to to belfast
and say look why don't you see how you
would try and get a power sharing
executive going
given all this but uh i i think that at
the moment we are still in a stage where
the uk government is is trying to use
the threat of legislation
to push us for a change in the eu's
negotiating position
all right james forsyth raphael bear and
katie balls thank you so much for
joining inspect htv
now you might think it's time to stop
talking about politicians breaking
covert rules but the reason it's still
an important story is because of the
ordinary brits who are still going
through the courts to deal with their
own inconsequential finds
michael simmons the spectator's data
journalist looks at this in this week's
magazine michael joins me now
so michael we've just been talking about
beer gate and party gate and a lot of
people i think are getting quite bored
with these stories thinking they're
quite trivial but you make the point in
your sidebar to katie balls's cover
piece this week that actually a lot of
people are still getting fined for
transgressions that were even less than
having a beer or having a birthday cake
can you tell us about these the cases
are still going through the courts right
now from covert
yeah so absolutely um
basically because a lot of the the
courts were obviously shot during the
lockdowns and the general um court
backlog built up it's exactly the same
with people that were fined during the
lockdowns and during the tiered
restrictions a lot of those cases are
kind of only just getting through the
court system now so in the weeks where
kind of partygate's been going on we've
still seen um that these 136 000 fines
across britain are being dealt with and
there's some kind of really interesting
examples of you know
fines for ridiculous things fines where
you think the people are banging to
rights and fines that are really similar
to and what's happened in part again and
beer gate and some of the examples on
the kind of bigger end uh there was a
student in leeds was fined ten thousand
pounds because as he says for a joke he
made the same facebook event to say oh
let's have a big snowball fight
and then within a couple of hours he
thought this joke's a bad idea it's got
out of hand so he deleted the event but
and hundreds of people turned up to this
park where the snowball fight was to be
anyway and he ended up with a ten
thousand pound fine
um on the 18th of december which is the
day of one of the downing street alleged
christmas parties um a pub in devon also
had its own christmas party and the
landlord of the pub ended up with four
thousand pounds worth of fines and he's
kind of really miffed about this because
as far as we know nobody in downing
street has been fined more than 50
pounds so far so there's kind of the
question about there seems to be a
certain discrepancy between uh between
fines
the other interesting thing with the
fines is if you do choose to contest
your fine which by the way most people
don't from the data we've seen only
about two percent of fines actually get
contested and then you end up going
through the court processes the judges
are kind of not really interested in
much mitigation or what your actual
covert risk war was so as an example and
the regulation about not being in
gatherings of more than two people and a
judge has said you know in court
documents that there's essentially no
defense to this if you're with more than
two people and then that's you uh you've
broken the law and a couple of kind of
harrowing examples of this and one was
an elderly man and who was quite he said
he felt quite lonely and he went to
visit his allotment and there he was
found chatting to people at the
allotment and he ended up with a fine
similarly there was a lady who had been
helping with child care with somebody
who was in a support bubble which was
allowed and it was the child's birthday
so she went round to the mother's house
and to drop off a birthday card she
didn't go in the house she says and but
when she got there she didn't realize
that the the person she went to see had
guests rounds illegally and because she
was essentially caught on the doorstep
she ended up with a fine and again the
magistrate judges are kind of not
interested or they don't seem to be as
interested in these defenses and the
people that will end up being fined it's
incredible because the examples you have
you know people's fines obviously range
from the customary 100 pounds which is
50 pounds if you pay it in half the
amount of time to 10 000 pounds as you
say we talk about this you know cost of
living crisis and you know i can
understand if you organize a massive
event as the student uh was accused of
doing you have to pay more but you know
for people like this pensioner just
being present while other people are
there outdoors which we now know is not
so bad for the virus um and the fact
that he's getting a fine 100 pounds it
does seem pretty shocking
you'd mention this discrepancy between
the devon landlord and downing street
party happening on the same day is that
because it's like a racking up of fines
as you go uh with different multiple
transgressions as it were
yeah so the the case of the the devin
landlord seemed to be that essentially
he was fined twice on the one day and
because of kind of the severity of him
being the the owner of the pub and the
alleged um event organizer and and then
i think he then committed a as another
offense that was similar so the fines
racked up and again you might say well
is this not similar to kind of some of
the alleged events we've heard about
from downing street but what's really
interesting when you look at some of the
reporting around the court cases is that
not only can there be discrepancy
between cases there's even cases where
there's discrepancy in the same incident
so one example was from a chippy or a
chip shop in notting hill where and the
owner had decided that he needed to have
a crisis meeting or what he called a
crisis meeting and to discuss some
staffing issue so all the staff went
around his house and they were spotted
and reported and the police came and and
the police felt that um this was a
meeting that although business meetings
were allowed at that time there was no
reason why this meeting wasn't held
online so the police um issued everyone
with fixed penalty notices and some of
the cases ended up going to court and
two of the staff and one pleaded guilty
and and they ended up with a fine i
think it was around 600 pounds and but
another member of staff on the exact
same evidence and didn't enter a plea
and ended up being acquitted so actually
within the same incidents we're seeing
discrepancies as well and also across
the country isn't there because
throughout all our discussion of this
we're talking about the metropolitan
police in london versus the durham
police and they have different standards
which is something that you write about
in your piece as well that durham
police has been a bit more lenient i
mean the problem at the end of the day
is that these covers rules probably just
not clear enough not well drafted enough
in order to ensure consistency when
applied across the country and you say
you end up with weird
exceptions
yes exactly so if we look at the
the data that's available from the
police and you do see kind of variations
and between forces and a lot of that
will have been because of the different
lock down tiers and because of
populations but for example durham
police which you mentioned i think i say
in the piece and i've so far issued
about 1 000 fines whereas in north
yorkshire which is a neighboring force
and i think is issued over 4 000. so
there's that discrepancy there i think
the other issue is especially after the
first lockdown and we got to know a bit
more about covid about how it didn't
tend to track you couldn't really catch
it outdoors i think people started to
apply their own common sense and you can
argue whether they they should or
shouldn't have done that i think people
decided right if i'm going to meet
someone i'll do it outside because i'm
least at least it's safe and the problem
is the law essentially didn't allow you
to make that your own judgment and what
see it looks like anecdotally is some
police forces have sort of said okay
we'll we'll become more lenient because
of common sense where other police
forces have said no we're rigidly we'll
apply everything kind of to the
letter of the law but what's interesting
as well is the attitude seems to have
changed kind of within magistrates
courts as well because if you look at
the some of the earlier cases and i saw
one current um was that only around 1 of
people were who claimed they weren't
guilty were sort of winning their cases
but now that's gone up to about 15
so
it's it's kind of unlikely that oh you
know suddenly people were 15 like less
guilty later on it's more that the kind
of magistrates attitudes have changed
and that it's been pointed out by
various legal watchdogs that that
suggests that actually many maybe of
these past fines and convictions are
sort of unjust and perhaps even unlawful
and it's incredible you know we talk
about this backlog in the courts that
you know transgressions like going to
your allotment and talking to your
neighbors are still going through the
courts as you say 100 over 100 000 of
them and just finally michael what if
you decide not to pay your fine what
happens uh if you just put your foot
down and say
i'm going to appeal but my appeal has
been a failure but i'm just not going to
pay the fine
yeah so if you don't pay and within your
28 days and you will probably end up
with a case before the magistrates
courts
and the majority of these cases are
dealt with for this legal mechanism
called the single justice procedure and
that's a procedure that's it's designed
really to keep people sort of out of
actual courtrooms and and it's designed
more for things like non-payment of the
license fee and people have been quite
critical of this single justice
procedure because it means that your
case isn't heard in open court
essentially it's done what as they call
on the papers you sort of writing your
plea and your evidence and then um a
magistrate and a legal adviser will kind
of sit and adjudicate and and that's not
really done in a courtroom in earlier
stages of pandemic you know literally
the magistrate could be um working from
home and it was really hard to find out
through public court listings where
these were going on and in westminster
magistrates as an example they ended up
designating this on their court lists as
courtroom 78 which isn't a physical
courtroom that actually exists so in
insiders kind of say this has now become
the name for these cases as oh it's a
courtroom 78 case
and and you say that what you know you
can just if you missed the letter you
could just not know that you you've been
served one of these and one man found
out that he was being fined through his
local paper
yeah absolutely so um i think the male
had reported this that there was uh
there's a man in reading who i think it
was a fairly minor um misdemeanor that
he kind of committed and with these
single justice procedures there's no
sort of requirement for you to be served
with papers or for like receipt of
papers so if you get this fine you don't
pay it because like you say that you've
not received any court documents and the
court will still hear your case assume
you're not engaging and then you can be
issued with your fine and local
newspapers will go through these kind of
charge lists and report you know such
and such joe blogs and has received his
fine and this unfortunate man you know
discovered that he'd been fined were
literally for reading his local paper
incredible michael simmons thank you so
much for joining spectator tv
across the world australia is in the
middle of an election campaign this week
alexander downer the former australian
high commissioner to the uk and
previously a politician for the
centre-right liberal party writes about
the main issues deciding the election in
the magazine
so alexander welcome to spectator tv and
thank you so much for joining now you
write about the australian election in
your piece this week tell us what is
going on there does it look like the
incumbent prime minister scott morrison
can win another term
i think it's going to be very hard for
him there are still two
ten days to go until the election so
there's a little way to go and a lot
will happen in that time as new issues
emerge but as things currently stand
scott morrison and his party the liberal
party are behind in the polls
um so at this stage labor are looking in
the box seat
um and it's it's not impossible that the
liberals won't turn that around but it
will be hard for them to do so
what are the main issues that they're
fighting on and maybe you can just give
a brief overview and then we can talk a
bit more about each of those
well first of all there's the economy
there's just as in the uk there's the
increase in the cost of living and
people are saying that they're hurting
and wages aren't increasing as fast as
the cost of living is
increasing this of course is a
consequence of the
huge increase in funding there's been in
australia and elsewhere in response to
the pandemic
and the increase in energy and food
prices across the board as you can see
in the uk and everywhere else
um so that that is an issue the liberals
uh scott morrison and his team they're
saying
that um this is a difficult time for the
australian and global economy and
the public should remain with the
responsible economic managers who have
seen australia through the pandemic the
economy is now growing unemployment's
only four percent they save jobs
um investments picking up so
stick with the known quantity don't take
a risk with labor whereas labour are
running the unsurprising argument that
people are really battling with the
ever rising costs and wages on keeping
pace and their living standards are
falling and they're doing it people are
doing it tough
um so that is a central issue in the
campaign
now secondly
there is the issue of china
and um
basically that has been a strong suit
for the
for the government for scott morrison
because he's been very robust in
standing up to bullying from china
and the public have been on site with
that but there's an issue that's come
out of less left field
which is china signing a security
agreement with a small neighboring
country the solomon islands and the
labour party are making the point that
it's all very well to talk tough with
china but you've let the solomons
sign a security agreement with china
without stopping it and you haven't made
enough effort to stop it
um and the liberals are saying well um
there's not much we could do about it
which is a fair argument actually
because
china's um spending in the solomon
islands doesn't match the kind of
spending that has the australian aid
program focus on
china's spending um some of china's
spending is going on politicians
and of course a country like australia
can't match that and can't can't morally
and ethically try to match it
but that's that's become a bit of an
issue and then finally there's the
climate change issue less an issue in
this election
than in a lot of previous elections but
nevertheless still an issue and even
though australia has signed up to net
zero by 2050
the opposition and also independent
candidates in a lot of safe liberal
party seats
um uh are doing well on this issue by
saying well we will do more
um we have a climate emergency and more
needs to be done
not that of course australia is going to
change the overall global outcome
australia only contributes 1.3
of anthropogenic um co2 emissions
worldwide
but nevertheless it is an issue
um and you know people are very
concerned about the climate that's
obviously a reasonable percentage of the
population
are moving away from the government on
that issue
well that's a brilliant overview of the
three you know hot topics as well i just
wanted to pick you up first on the
economy you talk about um this record
low unemployment all of these brilliant
gdp numbers that are coming out um i was
interested by what you were saying about
how covert has changed voters
expectations of what government funding
should look like because you talk about
this kind of historic economic
rationalism of australian voters and how
the pandemic has changed that he talk us
through that
we're going right back to the
troubled times in the 1970s which all
countries had australia went through
in the 1980s and the 1990s a a period of
very dramatic economic reform of
liberalizing the economy balancing the
budget indeed by 2007
the australian government had no net
debt at all
and
ran a budget surplus of about one and a
half percent of gdp
and so the arguments for maintaining a
balanced budget and having no debt and
so on were all very potent arguments
with the public and
when opposition parties would come out
and promise all sorts of spending on
no
man or all manner of worthy causes the
public understandably would raise the
questions yes well that all sounds very
nice but how would you ever pay for it
what has happened through the pandemic
is
in australia as elsewhere
there has been a massive increase in
government spending and of course the
imposition of huge illiberal regulation
on the public
and that has all been very popular
and so now all of those arguments about
balancing the budget and
fiscal rectitude
liberalized economi a liberalized and
competitive economy and so on those
arguments aren't cutting through with
the public anymore the public just think
well
um it seemed to be possible to increase
spending massively without any
consequence so that's a good thing so we
should be spending still more on
any manner of worthy causes
and they're not any longer
being troubled by the consequences of
that massive increase in government
spending and quantitative quantitative
easing by
the central bank even though
the inflation that we're seeing
everywhere is partly it's not not
totally but is partly a consequence of
the huge amount of money that is now
washing around in the economy
and chasing approximately the same
quantity of goods and services
um but that that that argument isn't
really resonating with the public at
this stage and they're
they're blaming the government the
australian government for inflation and
for price increases
and of course realistically there's
nothing the government can do about it
they say well we had to spend all of
that money to compensate for the
lockdowns and restrictions of
um of the pandemic
and and
you know we'll gradually reduce spending
but um you know this always going to
take a great deal of time and inflation
is a worldwide phenomenon it's not just
an australian phenomenon
um the reserve bank the central bank the
equivalent of the bank of england has
increased interest rates
um just last week um as they did the
bank of england did in the uk and the
reserve bank in the us has done
um and the public's response to that is
well that's going to make life still
more expensive for us and
um you're not managing the economy well
enough um
so that's the sort of zeitgeist of the
country at the moment and it's very very
difficult for the incumbent government
to respond to that and
you know it's it's one thing to say that
the response should be to provide still
more support for the public
um to help them with the increasing
uh prices but of course the extra
spending that you put in there would
have to be financed and yeah that in
turn is going to be inflationary and
push up interest rates still further but
and that's that's the economic truth of
it but it's very hard to get that
message across to the public at least
for the time being i mean in time the
public will tweak to that argument but
in the short term they're certainly not
responding to it well it's fascinating
how many of these political themes that
you pick up uh in australia are very
similar to what the uk has seen as well
in all of these areas and along china
you mentioned that scott morrison's
government has been standing up to
china's bullying obviously famously
china over the last few years has been
variously boycotting australian coal
australian wine australian beef in
response to scott morrison's government
calling for an independent inquiry in
jakob's origins but alexander i wondered
what you think about this i was having a
conversation with someone
in the australian government here in
london um and they were saying that
actually scott morrison didn't mean to
create so much of a fuss with china by
calling for that inquiry as he then got
that there was kind of a lack of
understanding that china would hit back
in the way that it did
do you think that rings true to you that
there was a kind of general ignorance
about what the chinese care about what
the chinese might do in return and you
know what does that mean for australians
relationship with well i think that i
think that's an unfair way of
sorry
i think that's an unfair way of
describing
the problem i mean it was an entirely
reasonable proposition
for the australian government to say
there should be an independent inquiry
into how covert
occurred and and how it spread
i mean who would argue with that given
the huge damage it's done to the global
economy and the lives that have been
lost as a result of it and it would be
unnatural not to have an
international and independent inquiry
into it to try to get to the heart of it
what has changed has been china um and
in particular not the people of china
but the chinese leadership
um under xi jinping they have become
more arrogant more aggressive and
they've decided to take
a baseball bat to australia and to
punish australia and i think they
particularly wanted to single out
australia because
it's a significant country it's an
important country in the indo-pacific
region but economically it's quite
dependent on its trade with china about
30 percent of australia's exports go to
china
and so china
obviously made a decision
using its wolf warrior diplomacy that it
would make an example of australia and
that would frighten others off from
criticizing china
and the australian government's response
to that has been entirely appropriate
which is that we're not going to be
bullied by anyone
in particular a bunch of communists in
beijing
and they have stood up to china and they
they have stood up magnificently and
courageously to china
and they have been supported by the
australian public there's no doubt about
that but no i mean you can't blame the
australian government and for the change
in tone and attitude of the government
in beijing they have become
arrogant and aggressive rude
they've imposed as you mentioned
sanctions on australian exports
and it's a preposterous way for them to
have behaved whereas
in years prior to that including for the
nearly 12 years i was the foreign
minister china wanted to work with and
cooperate with a significant regional
country like australia and they did well
um
building um
the imports
from australia that they need to
prosper they need those inputs they need
iron ore they need energy coal and gas
they need food from a country like
australia and australia has always been
a reliable supplier so to turn on the
australian government and the australian
people in the way they've done
it's been a known goal for china it's
damaged their economy it's pushed up
their energy prices and now you know the
china's economy is flatlining they're on
the precipice of going into a recession
not just because of that
um and that partly because of their
endless lockdowns and zero covert policy
which had been madness
um but but in any case um you know
that's the old strategy when you're an
autocrat if things all start going wrong
you blame the dreaded foreigner
yeah absolutely and the chinese economy
is estimated to grow at about five five
percent this year which is the lowest it
has been in decades um you're certainly
right alexander
yeah absolutely lucky if their economy
grows by as much as 5 because they've
also had
um severe problems with their property
market as well they've over invested in
property
um and and
what's more they they have taken away a
lot of the liberal market um structure
of their economy and made it much more
centrally controlled and autocratic yeah
it's all about the power plays in china
so you know they've made one mistake
after the other the country's been
really badly managed and its foreign
policy is a catastrophe alienating the
world as it has done jumping into bed at
the time of the
winter olympics in beijing with uh
president putin
and perhaps tipped off that he was going
very quickly to take over ukraine
and now china have found themselves
globally on the runs wrong side of that
argument of course they've retreated a
bit from their
um love affair with russia but um you
know it's just an example of the
catalogue of mistakes that the chinese
leadership have been making yeah i mean
i certainly don't think economics is
what drives their decision-making
anymore but anyway we have to leave it
there alexander downer thank you so much
for joining spectator tv
how far is oxford to blame for britain's
problems financial times journalist
simon cooper's new book chums looks at
how graduates from the university have
come to rule our country
toby young in his column for the
spectator this week doesn't quite agree
to debate the topic simon and toby join
spectator tv
simon cooper and toby young welcome to
spectator tv now simon could you start
by outlining your new book's thesis
it's about how oxford is so dominant in
the uk politically and has been since
the war i mean 11 of the 15 post-war
prime ministers went to oxford
and you know these are people from a
whole range of different political views
so we're talking thatcher harold wilson
tony blair david cameron boris johnson
really the whole
left to right of british power
and the book then focuses on the sort of
period
1993
where again the people who will go on to
lead labor including kierstarma balls or
the milibands are there the people
around david cameron who will then lead
the remain campaign on their chiefly
cameron and osborne and then the people
i spent most time talking about are kind
of small minority uh within the wider
remain let's say oxford
the people who will go on to lead the
brexit campaign
and now rule the country so
boris johnson michael gove jacob
rees-mogg so it's not that oxford is a
hotbed of brexit
because brexiteers are always a minority
there but these are the people who sort
of won the competition in our time so
it's about oxford it's about the current
ruling class
and the grip of oxford on on uk power
but you do draw a causal link there
don't you because as you say brexit is
our minority but you draw a causal link
between the culture of oxford and what
it encourages and how these as you call
them chums came to bring about brexit
and rule the country
i don't think there's a strong causal
link between oxford and brexit i think
there's a strong causal link between
oxford and power and there has been in
every generation
and so you know if you look at harold
macmillan in some ways he is a proto
boris johnson has a very very similar
path
into oxford and then their paths
separate because of history because i
mean mcmillan's second year i think
world war one breaks out and he leaves
oxford forever
but i think that
this group of people who i'm discussing
who are important because they they made
this huge change in the uk of brexit and
now they rule
they decided to use that power
for brexit
and i don't think that's an
inevitability of oxford at all
okay all right um toby
in your column for the magazine this
week you write that simon's book
contains incitements to class war topped
with a bit of workery pokery i guess you
don't agree then
well um i should start by saying cindy
that um i very much enjoyed simon's book
um it's a very entertaining read i
devoured it in one sitting um it's full
of amusing anecdotes um about that
period um and i think some of the um
stuff um documenting what went on behind
the scenes at the oxford union and
elsewhere um struck me as spot on and
very well reported um so um you know i i
want to caveat everything i'm about to
say by by stressing you know what an
enjoyable entertaining read this book is
i mean particularly for me because i was
someone who was you know at oxford in
that period but i'm sure it'll be of
interest more widely um but um i do have
some reservations about um simon's um
hypothesis i mean he was i thinks being
slightly um cagey there
my reading of the book
is that you were very much trying to
attribute um the brexit project in
particular um to
um a sort of
group of tory toffs who were typical of
oxford and typical of oxford in this
period and there is this sort of marxist
analysis that it was an expression of
class interest that really it was about
this group of toffs who thought they
were born to rule slightly cross about
the fact that westminster's delegated or
transferred some of its powers to
brussels and wanted to repatriate those
powers so they could then march into
westminster and claim their birthright
to sort of masters of the political
universe and i think that i mean there
may be a sort of kernel a grain of truth
there but i think that um the problem
with it is sort of twofold first of all
um uh uh just superficially lots of the
people who um led the brexit project
from that generation of oxonians like
michael gove and boris johnson even
jacob rees-mogg
are not exactly to the manor born
they're not sort of conventionally posh
particularly michael gove one of the
architects of the whole campaign so i
think there's there's a slight there's a
slight any action actually the people
who campaign for remain from that oxford
generation david cameron um rory stewart
um george osborne jeremy hunt uh nick
bowles hugo dixon we're actually a lot
posher than the people um uh who who
were on the other side so trying to link
it to you know a sort of fading ruling
class trying to kind of reassert its
dominance and reclaim its birthright
that that struck me as a little bit
simplistic and also at odds with one of
the kind of
points the book makes which is that
politics in britain big political policy
debates aren't discussed with the
seriousness that they should be and this
feels a bit like a kind of slightly low
blow and ad hominem attack on the kind
of architects of brexit not the kind of
serious point i thought
simon wants us to kind of bring up when
discussing a big policy issue but i
think that the fundamental flaw with
this hypothesis which i write about in
my spectator column this week is that
actually um remaining in the eu was
plainly in my view anyway um uh uh more
in the interests of britain's you know
ruling class than coming out of the eu
and that pattern was um you know that
was reflected in the pattern of votes on
you know june 23rd in 2016. it was a
genuine coalition between you know this
elite of oxford toritoffs as he calls
them and you know vast swathes of
ordinary people across the country
whereas romain wasn't able to put that
coalition together i think in part
because remaining in the eu was
identified with a particular class a
kind of class of globalists um anywheres
i think because
david goodhart calls them and and and
that was really uh
why they lost so i think he sort of
fundamentally misunderstood brexit and
trying to kind of trace it to this group
of kind of um uh sort of cynical
non-serious kind of tory toffs at oxford
i think it's a little bit simplistic
simon
i would take issue with some of the
things that toby said there i mean this
is not a book that tries to explain why
17 million people voted for brexit they
had many reasons
i'm not suggesting that boris johnson
manipulated all these people obviously
there were attempts to manipulate but
that is that is what politics does so
the reasons why people voted for brexit
i think have been discussed in other
books what i look at here is the people
who led
um the brexit push
without whom it couldn't have worked i
mean if you just had nigel farage as the
leader of vote leave the only person
saying we must do this and you get like
the 1975 referendum it becomes against
fight for the fringe with somebody who's
not seen as a responsible leader it
wouldn't have happened so you needed
people like johnson and government
so i look at those people who then after
they win the referendum they jettison
farage and they become power now i don't
call them in the book a ruling class i
call it a ruling cast i mean that's a
subtitle because i don't think and i say
i don't think they're pursuing kind of
narrow economic interests in this
marxist way that you accuse me of i
don't think they thought
our
class needs brexit to protect its
economic interests which would be a
marxist analysis or anything at all i
think it's a much more aesthetic choice
it's about um
attachment to british tradition and also
as i say in the book the idea that we
are the people
who from the age of eight are destined
to go to westminster and rule the
country and we don't want people from
brussels uh pushing in on that
and what they want to do with it with
their power in westminster is not so
much to protect
uh some kind of vested economic
interests of their
caste which anyway is becoming less
economically significant as other people
gain
economic power in britain it's a much
more about we are the people who
traditionally rule the country and we
want to do something great with that
power like our like britain did in the
past and now britain's becoming this
sort of rather disappointing you know uh
offshoots of the european union we want
more than that they're not typical of
oxford i mean oxford is a is a vast mix
of mostly upper class and then middle
class people like me and toby who
um probably were much larger in number
than the group of let's say boarding
school educated people
and that elite was divided yeah i mean
there were as you say there were people
like cameron and nick bowles who thought
that um romaine was the way forward for
britain
and so it's not that um
all those people all come out for leave
at all
but i'm looking at the people who did
come out to leave and were important and
i tried to investigate the reasons why
they did
um
yeah i think that covers my retort
but simon why link it to oxford at all
then if oxford produces all sorts of
people and if these people that you're
talking about are a minority why talk
about uh what assets the oxford union
for example gives you in terms of
debating why talk about the tutorial
system and what skills that gives you
link it to boris johnson's for example
rhetorical skills you know because your
book is called chums how a tiny cast of
oxford tories took over the uk and you
talk a little a lot about the
institutions of oxford as a university
and how that feeds into these people but
isn't aren't they going to be found
anywhere are they going to be found at
cambridge and other russell universities
if they're of course they could have
come from cambridge they could have come
from other universities or not from
university but the fact is
that the entire
ruling group of the different factions
in british politics in our time
with the exception of corbyn
uh farage he doesn't really have a party
they all come from oxford and so have 11
as they say 11 or 15 post-world prime
ministers so there's something very
interesting about oxford's grip on
british power that is worth
investigating it turned out that the
fact is i explained in this generation
that produced brexit that group of
people won but i mean if it had been
cameron
it would still i think have been worth a
book about oxford's grip on british
power
and then
the emphasis on rhetoric and the
tutorial system and the oxford union i
think
hugely affects the way that people who
end up in westminster um
rule and talk
sorry cindy i interrupted
no no no um i was just going to ask
bring toby back in um
to be you out at oxford during this
period you were contemporaries of many
of the characters and people that simon
writes about is this accurate are are
these heady days of what simon describes
what do you remember
um some of it is uh yes um uh very
evocative and um brought it all back um
and as i say i don't think he he gets
the detail of um what oxford was like in
those days wrong um but i think his um
rather jaundiced view of oxford um and
um of the kind of cult of the gentleman
amateur the fact that you know people
who go into politics generally don't
have a science background or a maths
background and that that kind of
humanities bias that cult of the
gentleman amateur has contributed to
britain's problems and accounts for the
fact that we didn't have a very serious
grown-up debate about brexit and he also
i think links it to
boris's
government being at sixes and sevens at
the beginning of a pandemic because you
know they didn't have any sort of
medical or scientific expertise and
couldn't really cope with something that
required a mastery of that kind of
detail i think that's sort of a bit
unfair i mean it's a fairly familiar
critique of oxford and of the kind of
british educational elite and i think
it's um i think it's slightly unfair in
that i'm not sure that people like boris
and certainly not david cameron were as
unserious as simon presents them as
being i mean to be fair to simon he does
quote dan hannon in the book saying that
when he spoke to boris about whether
boris was going to campaign for leave or
remain in 2015 boris agonized over the
decision and that was i had a
conversation with boris at his 50th
birthday party before he'd fully made up
his mind and i think agonizing over the
decision is a good way to put it he did
really seem to be wrestling with it
weighing up the pros and cons
recognizing that neither option um you
know that either option was sub-optimal
um and uh but it's it's it didn't it
didn't sort of suggest that he was just
this kind of you know dilla tante
treating it as a kind of debating topic
in the oxford union he was taking it
very seriously and he takes it seriously
because i think at bottom he's a
patriots and i think most of the people
who did campaign for brexit you know
however much you might disagree with uh
their point of view i think they thought
that it is in the best interests of this
country and campaign for it in good
faith i'll just pick simon up on one
particular point um he he he he remarks
frequently in the book on the dominance
of a kind of handful of elite public
schools um at oxford you know their
products are wildly over represented at
oxford compared to the products of the
school that simon and i went to turns
out we went to the same uh grammar slash
comprehensive in north london um that's
certainly true and i know i share i
share most people i think share simon's
misgivings about that um but um one
thing you overlook simon is that many of
the people you condemn as members of
this kind of superficial caste
of kind of you know um oxford union
hacks is that actually a a pretty
serious effort was made um under the
coalition government and and beyond to
try and reform british education to try
and improve standards in state schools
to try and make sure that oxford
cambridge the russell group more
generally wasn't as dominated as it is
by products of a few elite schools you
know michael gove i think was very
serious about that dominic gobe was
involved in that project david cameron
supported um gove and cared about that
himself you know if the if if in if your
kind of analysis which is that
this kind of cast of kind of toughs
wanting to kind of restore their
birthright and restore powers to
westminster so they could they could
then become masters of the universe and
it was all about perpetuating their own
privilege if that's correct then how do
you explain that they made this pretty
serious good faith effort to actually
reduce
the influence of of their class and
people from their schools you know
it seems to me it's a bit one-sided you
don't really you're not really quite
fair to um this group that you evidently
don't like very much and blame for many
of britain's problems
i mean there has been a push in recent
years in the last five years in
particular i would say to make oxbridge
in particular
uh more
fair in admissions
and so there's been a huge rise since
about 2017 in the number of state school
people getting into oxbridge i think at
oxford now at 68 state school which uh
in the last year which is the highest
ever recorded i mean a lot of those
people come from the posher kinds of
state schools
they um so it state school covers a
variety of sins so if you from a leafy
grammar in buckinghamshire that's a
state school
so
also it is totally not there yet but
things have got better
i agree that gov was serious about
making british education fairer i would
say the situation as it was when toby
and i went to university was just
totally unsustainable
i mean it's hard to think of a western
of a european country
with that level of unfairness in
admissions in the 80s so only about one
in eight people were going to university
at all and if you wanted to do classics
which typically meant that you come from
a public school your chance of getting
into oxford in the early 80s was two and
three it really was not that competitive
and just dozens and dozens of people
from public schools would come in so yes
oxford now if i rewriting a book about
oxford in 2022 it would be different
but the thing is that the elite is
produced 30 years earlier
that um
the people we see in power today come
from a past that i've tried to disinter
in the book just on lack of seriousness
i mean whether you're for against brexit
i didn't want to write a book about
brexit is bad brexit is good i'm against
brexit but i thought it would be
incredibly boring to write a book saying
brexit is a bad idea the whole product
nation has had that debate for six years
everyone's fed up with it nobody changed
their minds
but when you were four against in the
referendum there should have been
serious debates about the customs union
about the irish border about a divorce
bill about the single market how does
that work you stay in the single market
but you leave the eu what are the
modalities of doing that that was not
discussed by either side and so that to
me the referendum
whichever side you're on was not serious
enough for the task japan
simon just very finally i wanted to uh
something that struck me about your book
at the near the end was solutions that
you talk about to to not make oxford
this kind of elite hotbed
and you say that perhaps oxford should
stop teaching undergraduates so i just
wondered all your thoughts about that
because in light of the conversation
that we've just been having about how
much more diverse is becoming you know
full disclosure i went to oxford i did
ppe at christchurch one of the most
infamous colleges there but i went to a
state school and i'm also an immigrant
who wasn't even born in this country you
had to learn english at the age of 10.
oxford for me was life-changing if you
stopped taking undergraduates you know
you'd be denying opportunities to not
people like the future boris johnson but
people like me so how do you describe
that
well somebody like you i mean here we
are three state school people who went
to oxford and um ended up lucky
but how do you as somebody like you
could have gone to another university
that would have been great you could
have gone to the university of london or
uh you could have gone to
reading or bristol you could have had an
excellent experience because you're a
motivated intelligent person then you
could have gone to oxford 22 under what
i propose and do graduate work what i'd
love to see and i say at the end of the
book is an oxbridge for all that we say
you know you're 35 years old you didn't
go to university first time around or um
you didn't have a good or sufficient
experience you are not from a class that
was directed towards oxbridge but you're
bright you're intellectual we're going
to take you and you can have a year at
oxford or three months or whatever it is
that
that works for you we have time for and
so we spread the undoubted excellence of
a lot of oxford to a much broader part
of the population than just this really
rather small group of middle class plus
upper class people
that for most of
even today for most of the last few
hundred years it's been educated
so would you say not to end under
undergraduate teaching at oxford then
just spread the goodness a bit more
i i would i i just think it's
the grit the unfairness
of the selection essentially at age zero
rate six to oxford and therefore your
ticket to the establishment well not
quite in my case
not in your case but um unusual
exception i'd be interested in what tony
thinks
um well i i certainly think that um
uh you know more children from state
schools should be going to oxford and
cambridge and to elite universities more
generally and you know um i've i've
spent quite a lot of time over the past
um uh 10 or 12 years um trying to
trying to help um in various ways um you
know setting up um co-founding for free
schools at a multi-academy trust and
doing our best to encourage all the
children at those schools to uh aim high
educationally um but um i mean my
experience of oxford i think in some
ways was um different um to simon's um
and um seemingly i had a kind of
slightly better experience than he did i
mean that may be wrong
i had a really good time i really
enjoyed it i don't feel better
i was going to say that um
uh i um in the group of people studying
ppe at brazenos um who came up in 1983
um there were 10 of us i think and
within that group of 10 a huge
range of um political views from a kind
of
monday club kind of tub thumper on one
at one end to a kind of libertarian
conservative at the
whereas i went to harvard um a couple of
years after oxford and within the entire
harvard government department there was
nothing like that range of views it was
really just kind of people arguing about
different interpretations of liberalism
it was nozikian liberalism versus rawsi
and liberalism and that was really the
only debate and i like the fact that at
oxford there was this kind of huge range
of different opinions and it spoke of a
kind of pluralism a real intellectual
diversity accompanied by a good deal of
intellectual tolerance and real debates
about really important big issues and
and i think it would be a shame to lose
that and replace it with something kind
of more technical more vocational i
wouldn't say technical vocational i mean
if you're 35 and you didn't go to
university you're very bright and you
want to study shakespeare at oxford
great
but simon you can't have it both ways
either knoxville education is a good
that more people should be having or
it's bad and we shouldn't be giving it
to anyone
it's not either good or bad uh it can be
good and it can be bad i think that
there was a lot of kind of skating over
thin ice winging it lazing around uh
education wasted on eighteen-year-olds
who took their privilege for granted but
it also is not the highest one of the
highest-ranking universities in the
world for nothing
and the intelligent people going
ranking is mostly about research and
oxford has the largest research budget
of any european university it has
amazing academics
now much more than in the 80s because in
the 80s a lot of them didn't even have
phds and published in the paper
um and it does it does some fantastic
research and i think that um the
teaching it does
i would rather see spread
much more broadly to a much wider range
of talent
all right okay well i think we'll have
to leave it there simon cooper and toby
young thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
and finally why were photographers drawn
to palestine in the 1940s roger hardy's
new book the bride is a collection of
these wonderful photos and is reviewed
in the book section by the historian and
journalist justin marozzi to tell us
about his new book roger joins me now
roger hardy welcome to spectator tv
now your book is an illustrated history
of palestine palestine from 1850 to
about 1948. can you start by telling us
briefly what was going on in that time
well
western involvement
in palestine
involvement
motivated by politics but very much by
religion and in a way religion and
politics absolutely knitted together
um
we can say that i mean historically when
we think of religion of course palestine
was a holy land for the three great
monotheistic religions islam judaism and
christianity
but why did i start in 1850 because the
european
competition really for palestine for
influence in palestine really begins
innate around 1850 around the middle of
the century
because
the west had kind of lost interest
in palestine and in any case it was a
backwater it was an inaccessible place
under centuries of
rule by the ottoman turks it's been very
hard for people to go there
so in that time
or up to that time it was in a way a
country of the mind people imagined the
holy land of their sunday school classes
um they imagined a beautiful land um
still
frozen as it were into a into biblical
time
as if all those shepherds and guys
wearing funny robes
um were exactly the same as they were in
the time of christ wasn't true
but it was a nice idea
and beyond all that
the christian powers i'm talking about
the western powers europeans also
russians don't forget orthodox
christianity and then a little bit later
the united states uh united states comes
in
they
revere palestine they want it and in
some sense they want to possess it
which they never felt about i mean
british didn't feel that way about egypt
for example egypt had the suez canal it
was important but you didn't want to
desire it you wouldn't possess it
and so they're rivals with one another
the catholics against the protestants
the catholics and the protestants
against the orthodox
and each of those religious groups
has got an outside sponsor
a european power or russia will
later on
so it's the beginning
of the struggle for palestine
which reaches its climax at the end of
the story
and your book is full of amazing
pictures from
the century that you're looking at and
you talk about you know shepherds in
funny robes herding sheep but there is
really a picture like that that you've
got in here from the early 1900s but but
you've written about how it's been used
some of these pictures for propaganda
reasons can you tell us about that
you can look at a picture like that and
say well it's a nice picture i mean it
reminds me exactly of the children's
bible or the sunday school classes that
i attended rather unwillingly as i
remember
but you look at to me the question
um i'm not an expert on photography by
the way but i learned as i went along
and i had some really very very good
advisors
um
the key question is who took this
picture who asked them or paid them to
take this picture and why
we don't always know the answer but in
that case we do
they wanted to it was a staged
performance they wanted to recreate
psalm 23 the lord is my shepherd
and we actually know it gets slightly
funny that uh the
the the photographer and his assistant
were both from sweden they were
fundamentalist christians who'd come to
the holy land waiting for christ to come
again for the second coming
so larson sends ahead his young
assistant a guy called eric matson to
pay off the shepherd
and pay off the owner of the sheep so
it's like a stage performance and what's
the aim the underlying aim the implicit
aim
to
create or propagate the myth perpetuate
the myth that palestine is unchanged
since biblical times this is the kind of
guy that jesus would have encountered
it's not true it simply wasn't true but
an awful lot of people wanted to believe
that it was true
i also want to talk through a few of the
other incredible photos in your book um
for example you have one of a woman and
child walking through an alley
lined by barbed wire can you tell us the
story behind that
it's a slightly later picture
from the last
chapter of the book which as i say
reaches its de
and
i found
this is the moment which for israelis is
a moment of triumph they've created
their state the birth of the state and i
call it the improbable birth of the
state of israel there was nothing
preordained about it it wasn't destined
to succeed on the country it did succeed
but the palestinians lost out i call
them the victims of british failure the
failures of british imperialism the
british tried to rule palestine and in
the end threw in the tower
and walked away
in the fight that ensued the israelis
won
the israelis have their state to this
day
and the palestinians have
what they call the nakba the catastrophe
so i wanted an image of
the nakba what it means and what it
feels like for palestinians
and this was by finally enough another
swede a swedish
photographer called pair olive anderson
who went to the camps just afterwards so
the early 50s
and the woman is blind
and the little child leading her
and the camp is in gaza
and
the little girl is her grandchild
leading her
so it seemed to me a very strong image
of the nakba or the aftermath of the
nightmare the consequences of what all
this meant
for people who'd
lived and uh lived in their homes and
owned their land for centuries
um before
the zionists and their jewish
settlements uh with their jewish new
jersey settlements came
um is that a biased statement i don't
think so i mean it's historical fact
that the palestinian arabs had lived
there yes under ottoman rule and yes
palestine was not an independent entity
it was simply part a province of the
ottoman empire
but they lived there for hundreds of
years
um
and the jewish settlers of course uh
won they won through warfare
and in some sense the morality of the
whole issue of course fiercely contested
to this day
the the moral rights and wrongs
were subordinated by the fact of that
might is right
israelis won the battle for palestine
britain by that time had withdrawn so
there was nobody no outside power no
third party to stop the israelis winning
i'm not saying by the way it was easy
uh ben gurion the the the father of the
jewish state turned to his advisors when
war was about to start he said what are
our chances they said 50 50.
and they were right i think
and of course the israeli settlers and
the jews who came afterwards went
through their own fair amount of
suffering as well i thought you put it
very well when you said it was a moral
ambiguity at the heart of israel's
existence
which your book is all about
i think so and
what intrigued me i didn't know this
until i did the research over the last
six six or seven years it took me to
write the book
ben gurion's most recent biographer a
very brilliant israeli journalist and
writer called tom sego
in his biography of ben gurion says that
while publicly of course he defended
what israel did
israelis israeli actions in 1948 and of
course his own actions as being at the
center of the drama
but according to segev privately
ben-gurion was haunted for the rest of
his life
by the palestinian exodus
and
you're haunted by a ghost now why are
you haunted by a ghost in this case
without wanting to read ben gurion's
mind i think he knew
that there was a moral ambiguity at the
heart of israel's existence or at the
minimum at the very least
that there'd be people in the world
especially the western world which is
what he cared about most who would think
that there was a moral ambiguity an
element of doubt i found that very
revealing by a biography who
who's written a a brilliant book about
ben gurion
roger hardy thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
that's it for this week
once again we're delighted that
canaccord genuity wealth management is
sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
canaccord will provide the expertise you
need to build your wealth with
confidence you can visit can do wealth
dot com to find out more and don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode thanks for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
you